digamos que queremos resolver 8.38 4.54
pausa en este vídeo y traten de
resolverlo por ustedes mismos hay muchas
estrategias para resolverlo pero ya les
voy a decir la forma en que mi cerebro
lo hace yo veo esto como 8 y 38
centésimos y le voy a restar 4 y 38
centésimos y la razón por la cual puse
aquí 38 centésimos es que los quiero
cancelar voy a quitar estos 38
centésimos y así solo tendré que restar
un poco más aquí voy a restar 38
centésimos pero tengo que restar un
total de 54 centésimos así que veamos 54
por cuánto es mayor que 38 y lo estoy
haciendo en la mente ahora mismo para ir
de 38 a 54 necesito 6 y otros 10 más así
que necesito restar otros 16 centésimos
como fue que llegué a esto bueno 54 es
igual a 38 16 así que si tengo que
restar 54 puedo dividir
en 38 y 16 puedo restar primero 38
centésimas y luego restar 16 centésimas
porque decidí restar 38 porque coincide
con este y entonces digo 84 es igual a 4
y luego 38 centésimas menos 38
centésimas se van a cancelar entonces
esto menos esto es igual a 4 y luego
tenemos 4 menos 16 centésimas y cómo
podemos abordar esto bueno puede ser que
ya lo estén resolviendo en la mente
podrían decir ok le tengo que restar 16
centésimos a 4 y esto va a ser igual a 3
y 84 centésimas o tal vez quiera separar
esto y decir 4 es lo mismo que 3 y 100
centésimos
y ahora quiero restar 16 centésimos
entonces 100 menos 16 es igual a 84
centésimos
lo voy a escribir aquí 84 centésimos
y lo puedo escribir como 0.84 y cuánto
estrés 0.84 como lo hemos visto muchas
veces esto es igual a 3 y 84 centésimas
ahora como ya lo he dicho hay muchas
maneras de abordar este problema por
ejemplo otra forma que podría usar es
resolver primero las unidades 8 menos 48
menos 4 más ahora voy a tratar de
resolverlos decimos entonces tengo 3
decimos menos 5 decimos 0.3 menos 0.5 y
luego tengo los centésimos 8 centésimos
menos 4 centésimos 8 centésimos
- 4 centésimos ahora esto es muy fácil
de resolver y esto también es muy fácil
de resolver pero qué tal esto no tengo
cinco décimos para restar los que puedo
hacer aquí en lugar de tener este 8 voy
a tomar 1 y me van a quedar 7 y ahora
tengo un 1 que puedo reagrupar en algún
lugar por aquí puedo reorganizar esto y
entonces verlo como 7 + 10 décimos
y ahora puedo tomar estos 10 décimos y
sumarlos aquí
déjenme reescribir lo puedo describirlo
como 7 menos 4 más 10 décimos
más tres décimos
estoy mezclando diferentes maneras de
escribir esto pero funciona bien
- cinco décimos y esto ya lo puedo
resolver esto es cuatro centésimas más
cuatro centésimas esto que tenemos aquí
es igual a cuatro centésimas y ahora
cuál va a ser el resultado
7 4 es igual a 3 pies te decimos más
tres décimos es igual a 13 decimos menos
cinco décimos es igual a ocho décimos y
luego tengo cuatro centésimos tres
unidades ocho décimos cuatro centésimas
o 3.84